Build it draw it play it!
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it
Artist Guy Laramee makes hand carved landscapes
out of books.
He says mountains of disused knowledge return
to what they really are, mountains.
Some of his projects include Han Shan, The
Cave, The Great Wall, and Adieu from an Encyclopedia
Britannica set.
Eric Hart built a replica of the Game of Thrones
chest given to Daenerys in season one.
There are step by step instructions on what
he did throughout the process and he condensed
months of work into a seven minute video showcasing
his creation.
Sculptor Liu Xue created these hybrid human
and animal sculptures.
Each piece features a human head and some
sort of animal appendage and they explore
the ideas of physical beauty like this man
and pig, woman and a chicken, man and dog,
and this man horse.
Professional origami artist Sipho Mabona intends
to build a life-sized elephant to prove that
a simple piece of paper can be transformed
into anything imaginable.
With the help of 3 assistants the giant paper
elephant will be made out of a sheet measuring
15 by 15 meters and the final project will
stand over 3 meters tall.
Draw it
Qwerty is a project by artist Pablo Gamboa
Santos that superimposes typed letters of
an old typewriter to create landscapes.
He has more than 300 creations and they make
up a 60 meter long mural of some simple designs
and some that are more intricate.
Jaume Montserrat has an unraveling animal
series called Emptyland that combines different
species intertwined like this owl and kangaroo,
tiger and cheetah, penguin and rabbit, bear
and fox, and zebra snake.
And now for the hyper realistic pencil drawings
of Diego Fazio...
SpY creates humorous and thought provoking
street art that he says "are filled with equal
parts of irony and positive humor."
His project "cameras" involved installing
150 fake cameras on a building facade with
the intention of watching over nothing.
Play it
For those who see is a project by Daniel Schulze
that uses a 7x7 grid of speakers to shoot
rings of fog and help visualize sound.
Alan Silvestri performs an Acoustic rendition
of Back to
the Future.
Vsauce fan Daniel Ferri is a one man band
- here's his version of Madness by Muse.
Finally here is the video for I'm Aquarius
by Metronomy directed by Edouard Salier.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube or share them with everyone
over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio - music created and submitted
by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to only you creations.
And as always - thanks for watching!